Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. I'm your host, Rawkode.
Before we get started, I just wanna take
ten seconds to say thank you to my
employer, Equinix Metal. Equinix Metal is a bare
metal cloud, and they actually encouraged me to
keep producing that series and and all producing
quality cloud native content where we can all
learn together. So, you know, thank you to
them. If you wanna check out Equinix Medal,
please use the code Rawkode dash live. This
will get you $50 in credit, which is
roughly around a hundred hours of bare metal
compute time.
Alright. Today,
we're gonna be taking a look at Rust
again. This is part two. We've been walking
through the Rustlands exercises.
Today, I am joined by Manish Gorekakar,
a Rust core team member and the lead
of the Rust dev tools. Hey, Manish. How
are you? I'm doing great. How are you?
Awesome. Very well. Thank you. I'm looking forward
to learning more Rust today. So, you know,
definitely a good day.
Do you wanna just give us a little
bit of an introduction about yourself? Tell us
a little bit more about you.
Sure.
I mean, I I've been doing Rust since
2013,
'20 '14
before it was stable when Rust used to
break all the time. It was not really
a great time, but it was, pretty fun
to get involved, like, back then when there
was a lot of lot of chance to
make some impact on the language.
For the last four years, I've been,
working at Mozilla on
the Stylo web browser sorry, the Servo web
browser.
Stylo was a part of that. And,
actually, starting next week, I'm gonna be working
at Google on their internationalization
team doing a Rust internationalization
stuff.
Nice. Very cool.
Yeah.
Okay. So
I guess I should ask first. I mean,
have you've been using Rust a long time.
So you're probably not that familiar with the
Rustler's exercises. Have you done them before?
I have gone through them at some point.
I've poked around. I've suggested them to many
people, but I've not gone through them, like,
bit by bit
myself.
I've done, like, a couple and, like, read
through them. But yeah. Cool. Well, there have
I, so this should be fun.
Right. Let's oh, we have a hello.
Hey, Sangam. Nice to meet you. Hey. So
if anyone wants to do this on their
own time,
these are great exercises.
They've been recommended to me many times. So
this is why we're doing this today. They're
Rust dash Lang slash Rustlings.
We did do a few of them the
other day. Jesus. That was
Tuesday. Yeah. There we go. This is Friday.
That was Tuesday.
The way this works is I run Rustling's
watch.
It's gonna give me a few text and
say, yep, we did variables, we did functions.
I don't know why functions isn't there, but
it doesn't matter.
And so they're telling us that the next
exercise we wanna attempt
is conditional slash f statements. So we'll start
there. We may jump around a little bit
and we'll just see what happens.
We are using Versus Code live share today.
So Manish and I can both see the
same code. You also have the ability to
type and fix my very broken code, I'm
sure.
And we'll see what happens. So
if you doesn't catch us on Tuesday, the
format for these rustling seems to be that
we get some sort of test.
We then have something else that needs completed
for those tests to pass.
And then when we're happy with that, we
have to remove this I am done. Why
am I telling you we have to remove
the I am done? Because I will probably
forget. So, you know, I'll need a little
reminder, I'm sure.
If we take a look at these tests
Okay. So we have some sort of assertion
that 10
and then we get a bigger function which
should return. Alright. This seems
trivial. This is a nice easy start. Right?
This just wants me to do an f
statement to check for which number is bigger
between a and b.
Awesome.
Okay.
I remember correctly from Tuesday's session, the curly
brackets are optional in Rust. Is that right?
The
the parentheses in if and four are optional.
The curly brackets are mandatory.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Okay. Opposite of what, like,
JavaScript and c do. This is sometimes confusing.
Okay.
So it's I start I try it. It's
like Golang in this respect. Yes. Okay. Okay.
So we can say f a is larger
than b.
Oh, and then I remembered this. So Yes.
You don't have to write the return if
it's at the end.
Yeah.
I really like them as them bindings of
Versus code. They're so annoying that every time
I get, like, a complete here, I don't
know how to make it go away. Like,
if I push up and down
left and right. There we go. See, you're
solving problems.
Now
does this code look okay to you?
Looks
fine to me.
Alright. And so
a is better than b, return b. Now
if we can just recap some things for
anyone who wasn't paying attention or wasn't even
watching on Tuesday.
This syntax puts out a semicolon, can you
give me a refresher of of what that
means? So basically,
in Rust,
at the if you have, like, a block
and you can do, like, I don't know,
some work in the block,
and the last line, if you say, like
I don't know. If I say five with
a semicolon, this means that the block doesn't
evaluate to any value. But if I don't
have a semicolon at the end of a
block, I can actually do, like, x equal
to this. And
now the value of x is gonna be
five after doing all these things, which means
that
if you want to return from a function,
you can just put, like, five here, and
it's gonna return five at the when when
it reaches the end of a function as
long as you omit the semicolon.
Similarly, you can nest that. So
now what we're doing is you can see
the highlight. Yeah. Yeah. You can. We are
returning this since there's no semicolon after the
if, this function is returning this the value
of this if block. And the value of
this if block is either a or b
because we have omitted the semicolons at the
end of each of these blocks.
Ah, okay.
So I'm I'm curious. You know, you've got
a lot of experience here.
Is this idiomatic Rust or would you do,
like, an early return here? Like, if I
mean, if you were writing this code for
yourself, you're you're happy with that. This is
good. Right? This is idiomatic.
Some people prefer doing
explicit
returns.
Like, there's some preferences.
But,
typically, it is very idiomatic to do use
the use
the remove not you don't use a semicolon
for a return at the end of the
blocks and tags.
Okay. Like, it's it's very idiomatic to do
that because then you can kind of just
look at the end of the function and
be like, this is what the function is.
If a greater than b, it's a, else
it's b. It's easier to read.
Is there a nicer syntax for that? I'm
thinking about other languages that have, like, a
turn a a ternary operator where I say
greater than b. Like, is is there a
way of the imagine Rust without the We
don't have that operator. We use the question
mark for something else as well.
And and we don't have the operator in
part because this works, so you can just
write that if statement.
Python does the same thing. Like, I mean,
in Python in Rust, you you would just
write if you wanted, like, a one line
turner, you just write if a greater than
b
a
l s b, which is kind of weird.
But in Python, you'd also do, like,
a if a greater than b l s
b,
which is similar.
But yeah. It's it's we don't have a
ternary operator, but we do have this, which
is close enough in most cases.
Okay. I'll take it.
Alright. And I'm just making sure the test
cases here don't return two numbers as the
same. That would be mean, but it doesn't
look like they do. So Yeah. Let's see.
Did that pass? It did. So we can
then move our I am done,
and it should move us on to f
two. There we go.
Alright.
Let's see what we got. We got test
for a.
Expects a string and we have an integer.
A naive implementation, I can just do that
to fix the first problem. Right?
Yep.
But then my tests fail
because we're supposed to be running or returning
baz or par. Okay. So
get the bar for fuzz and default to
baz test passing.
If I pass fuzz, I get foo. If
I pass fuzz, I get bar.
I mean, that's it seems a bit weird,
but I'm gonna just make that pass then.
Like so fuzz is foo and fuzz is
bar.
Yep.
Fuzz
fuzz
bar else.
Fuzz. Yeah.
Okay. To test
There's a small mistake. But
Oh, what's my my mistake? You'd you'd need
the physicist here as well. Yeah. Yeah. Alright.
Okay.
This isn't like a switch or a match,
but we do have that.
K. So so that passes. So this is
now not idiomatic Rust. Is that what you're
saying there? That's what probably No. No. I
was saying that you've forgotten the physic here,
but you added it. Would you use a
match here instead?
Oh, for
three cases, maybe, maybe not. I would personally
use a match. I don't know if that's
really more idiomatic.
Like, for this is fine, I think, idiomatic
wise. I would personally use a match, but
yeah. Can you do you mind showing us
the match syntax? That would be cool to
So
match syntax would look like
Oh, wait. No. It's backwards.
And fuzz.
So these are strings.
And then
that's a wildcard.
And this should probably
this should probably work.
Alright. Let's see.
Yeah. Okay. Cool. So the match sent I
mean, that looks pretty familiar. Like, a switch
case and other c derivative style languages
Yep. I guess, similar to what I've seen
in at least it follows a similar flow
to what I've seen in, like, Alexa as
well. The underscore is familiar.
Nice. Yeah. That's much cleaner. I'd probably probably
go with that one.
Okay. Let's remove. I am done.
For the people that are watching, if you
have questions or any syntax that you want
us to try and help you with, if
you've been trying to learn Rust on your
own, feel free to drop that in the
comments, and Manish and I will do our
best to try and cover that syntax too.
Okay. What do we got next?
Primitive types.
If I remember, we actually skipped these.
They were a bit derivative.
So why don't we pick something else then?
Let's see.
Anything you think would be fun that you
would like to do on this list?
I don't know. Like, have you touched any
of the moving and borrowing stuff yet?
No. But I I would love to to
move semantics where we popped up and opened.
Yeah. Alright. Okay. Let's get our test passing
then. So Rust watch
move semantics
one.
Is it moo oh, I can't spell. Is
that the problem?
That
Let's try Rustling's
run.
Yeah. That works. Let's do that. Okay.
So we have a message here. It says
we cannot borrow back one as mutable.
It's not declared as mutable. Alright. So that
doesn't seem too scary yet.
Let's see.
Oh, yeah. So this push must be the
fail. So lane 13.
Yeah. Okay. So that I can fix.
I think.
Yep.
All it wanted was to be. That's
not what I was expecting from the move
semantics first one. Maybe it's just easiness in.
This is easing us in. This
is very much easing us in.
Yeah. In fact, like, this is not a
mute this is just a mutability thing. This
is not a move semantics yet.
Oh, okay. So this one looks this one
is definitely another message to do with the
move semantics then. Move occurs because vex needle
has a type which does not implement the
copy trait.
Yeah. That seems a bit scarier. So let's
see what we're dealing with.
So
we declare a mutable vector
for this function.
Yep.
Okay. I'm assuming the effect of one push
is okay, so the error message is online.
Oh, is that 13 again?
So
let's look at the error message closer. Or
Yeah. I mean, what we can I what
I can what we can do is go
through the error message or I can explain
what move semantics are first?
Yeah. Let's let's cover that. Yeah. Me with
the basics.
So in Rust, basically,
there's some types like numbers which are copyable.
So if you have a number and you,
like, assign that number to another variable,
it'll just make a copy. So now you
have two variables with a number in them,
and they'll independently change.
But some things like so in Rust, a
vector is allocated on the heap.
So there's allocation involved,
and
it can be arbitrarily large.
You really don't wanna copy that around.
What you want to do is
if if if you assign the vector to
a different variable, that variable is now where
the vector is. And the way Rust
and and to prevent various problems, what Rust
does is that it actually stops that vector
from being used from the old variable.
Rust is very careful about sharing.
When things are being shared, it wants that
to be explicit. It wants it it uses
the ampersand
to talk about sharing often, and it wants
it to be explicit if the shared variable
is mutable, immutable, and stuff like that. So
what's going on here is
that
when you so if you look at the
fillvec
signature, what it does is that it takes
the the takes the vector by move.
Like, the vector is being moved into the
function and then returned, so it's moved out.
So vec zero
actually
vec zero basically
left,
like is is the the vector left vec
zero here. It is no longer belonging to
vec zero. It it moved into the function
and out into vec one.
So vec zero is
not
not a valid
binding anymore. There's so we cannot read it
over here because it's gone already. It has
been moved out.
Does that make sense?
It does. Yeah. It does make sense.
So basically, in this line, we did a
move.
Yeah. Okay. So whenever we pass a variable
to another function,
that's considered
moved. Is that, like, the borrowing that we
always hear about when I read about Rust?
It is the opposite or is counterpart of
the borrowing. Right. Okay. You can pass a
variable to a function in a way that
it gets borrowed,
and then then that means that the function
is temporarily looking at it, but we did
not do that yet. We passed it to
the function in a way that got moved.
Oh, so if we passed it as a
bottle, then we wouldn't have this error as
well. Was that another okay. Is this line
21?
Is that something to common in Rust, or
is that just to kinda make this code?
It's it's yeah. So that that's actually
basically, the the variable mutability is not that
big a deal. Like, you could turn it
on and off, and that's kind of how
you'll turn it on. And that what what
this is basically doing is saying it's creating
a new variable that has the same effect
of the same name as the old variable,
but it's mutable.
There's another way of doing this, and I
think it was just done so that they
didn't have to introduce the syntax. But you
can also just say this, and this would
have also worked.
Yeah. I think I've I've seen that mutability
and the function signature before, and I was
just curious. So maybe that's was the more
idiomatic way. But you're saying that's actually just
to not introduce too many new concepts, probably.
Yeah. It's, yeah, it's probably to not introduce
too many new concepts. But this is called
re this is called chat rebinding, and this
is done pretty often.
Like, in Rust, everything's mute immutable by default.
So sometimes what people do is if they
want something to be mutable, they'll only temporarily
make it mutable, and this is how you'll
do that.
There's there's a different form of temporary immutability
that we can get to later, but this
this is the the variable itself being mutable
is something you can turn on and off
very easily.
Does that mean that it's also valid to
do
that? Yes. Yes. And that and that makes
it immutable again. Right? That would yeah. Because
what's what's happening is that you're just creating
a new variable named vec that shadows the
old variable named vec, and you're moving it
from the old vec into the new vec,
the compiler easily sees that these are two
separate things. But from your point of view,
the old ones
be like, the moment you name like, you
can also do something like let vec equal
to five,
and now
the vec
there is now a new variable called vec
that's whose value is five, and that vector
is kinda gone.
You can't access it anymore. So, like, that's
that's just called shadowing. You can create variables
of the same name as old ones, and
they will you can just use them normally.
And does that take up double the amount
of space? Can I consider no? It doesn't.
Okay. Well, if you do let at vac
equal to vac, no. It is this is
this this compiles down to nothing. Alright.
Should have compiled down to nothing. Sometimes
compilers are weird, but
yeah.
Okay. So let's see if we can fix
this code then.
So what we're saying is we have this
empty vector called vec zero. Yeah. We then
pass it into a function, which then means
it's now moved.
So vec zero is no longer a reference.
Right. So
I guess we have two.
One option.
Do we make this a bottle,
or do we clone it? I'm not sure.
I guess I guess one of the
I guess one of the issues here is
what do we want
the
what do we want the
like, what do we want the actual semantics
of this program to be? Because what we
do here matters.
So it tells us not to change this
line. So from my head, we've gotta make
sure that back zero is still is still
binding to the value.
Alright. So so what we can do here
is
the the easiest way to do this is
that we copy that we create a copy
of vex zero. Like, so far, we have
not had this problem because
all the things we've been dealing with have
been copyable.
That if if you if you just say
that let mut vec one equal to fill
vec vec zero and it's vec is a
number,
it'll just copy it. You won't have this
problem.
And what's happening here is that it's what
we one way to solve this is just
to make a copy. And the way you
do that in Rust is called it's called
cloning,
and cloning is just when you make an
explicit deep copy.
This, of course, is going to create a
new vector.
It's gonna take a make a new allocation,
do an entire copy of everything in the
vector, which is right now nothing.
The vector's empty.
And then give it to this function. So
this function will have us different vector and
vex zero will stay its pristine empty self.
Okay.
So I I mean, I do have a
couple of, like, hobby projects that I've been
trying my best to write in Rust, and
then keep getting frustrated. And I do find
myself using dot clone just all the time
as, like, my escape hatch for things like
this.
That is totally fine. I think once people
understand
the I think as as a newcomer, it
is fair it's a good idea to use
clone a lot.
And, actually, I would recommend that even as
an advanced Rust programmer,
you should probably be using clone a lot.
You you'd probably know enough to be able
to write this code to avoid copies,
but you really
you really don't
need to in many cases. This is often
a premature optimization.
So if you need to clone, just clone.
And, like, if it becomes a performance issue,
you can go back and think of how
else could you have done this.
Like, one way to do this without cloning
in this case, by the way, the clone
is free because empty vectors aren't actually allocated.
But if the if the vector did have
things in it, it would not be free.
Yeah.
That's good to know.
So let's stick with the clone approach then.
I'm glad that you've validated that for me.
I always felt like I was cheating every
time I did it, but now I'm okay.
It's yeah.
Let's see. It's happy. Right? Nice. So
we've got move semantics
three.
Let's see what we're dealing with here. So
no test.
Make me compare without adding new lines.
No lines with multiple semicolons necessary.
Alright. Okay.
So we initialize an empty vector.
We do the same thing here.
And then this one hasn't printed in back
zero, so that should be fine. We then
gotta push here,
but with no assignment.
So the problem is here that sec one
is no longer
at the same location. Is that right?
That might vac one equal to fill vac
vac zero.
Print
vac one and vac one dot push.
I guess I should read the error message.
Because I'm trying to work out, is this
vec dot one dot push part of the
move semantics because it's a function on a
struct? No? No. So this is a function
that takes a mutable borrow. Actually, if you
I guess, Versus code will do this. If
you highlight on the push, like, if you
just put your cursor on the push, it
should do you see the and mute self?
Yep. Yeah. That is that
is a mutable borrow. And what that is
saying is that for the duration of this
function,
please give me exclusive access to mutate and
read this object.
And once I'm done with this function, you
can go back to having it. So that's
where the borrowing comes in.
And that, of course, we that's not actually
moving it. That's, like, temporarily
doing something. So move semantics
it it doesn't break the move semantics.
Okay. Let me get the actual error message
then instead of guessing. That would probably be
a good start.
Okay.
So we've got cannot borrow vec as multiple
oh, okay.
So oh, yeah. The problem's here.
Yeah. So the syntax you used showed us
was we could do that, but we could
also have done Yeah. But we're not allowed
to add lines. Yeah. So now we know
why it didn't use that syntax in the
last case because it wanted to teach us
the syntax here. Yeah. There was methods there.
Yeah.
If let's see how far that gets. That's
it. Alright. Okay. So I'm sitting here looking
for some sort of move semantic in this
function that doesn't even exist. No. Okay. No.
The Rustlings try not to introduce, like, a
billion concepts,
like, one after the other. So they it's
it's a very smooth ride.
Nice.
Okay. Let's read the error message before I
open the file then.
So move semantics four
is
found macro vac.
Okay. Yeah. So missing
the exclamation mark. Right? Let's see.
Is it?
Or or well, okay. So it says use
this to invoke the macro.
Yeah.
And
okay. Refactor this code so that instead of
having vec zero and creating
the vector and function main, we instead create
it within the fill back. Okay. So
Yep. Does the macro need the parens as
well? Yeah. It needs some form of yeah.
Okay. It needs a parens or yeah.
Doesn't matter.
Oh, really?
Oh, yeah. Rust macros there are some some
depicts here, but, like, Rust macros, the ones
that are like this one,
you can do this. You can even do
this.
It does not matter,
which is why but people use this because
this looks like the array syntax. So if
you're making a vector, you'll make it look
like an array.
Also means that if you wanna fix stack
array, you can just kinda remove that if
you want. Alright.
Okay.
Well, let's see if that's all at once.
No. We got more. Okay.
Ah, yes. So we're still passing in,
you know, so we can.
Yeah. We don't need to do that anymore.
There we go.
This is also more idiomatic Rust because you
typically want if if a function is, like,
returning something, you want the and and the
function needs it freshly created, it's better if
the function creates it. There's no need to
freshly create it and pass it in. We
don't do out parameters and stuff like that.
Alright. Okay. That's good to know as well.
So that's most semantics. That that means I
know everything I need to know now about
that,
which I don't think is really true yet.
So There's there's borrowing and I like, we
touched a little bit on borrowing. I don't
actually know if they're tits,
if they're Rustlings for that,
but there probably are somewhere. I I I
suspect Rustlings in my I in my recollection,
Rustling kind of teaches
you borrowing bit by bit, like, in pieces
instead of, like, having a here is a
thing where we'll teach you just borrowing.
So
yeah. Okay.
Well,
let's pick something else. And then if we
don't find anything else that maybe hints towards
what the borrowing stuff is, we can always
reopen
move semantics for later and then just make
that function to borrow and kinda go through
that process. We don't want it to do
a borrow in this case. It's
yeah. There but we can we can have
examples of borrowing at some point, I think.
Alright. Okay. Let's see. Let me just
I'll pick one at random. How about
options?
Sure. Yeah.
Alright. So we got option one.
Back error message? Okay.
So print number function expects an option and
it found an integer.
Okay.
So it's kind of
looks like generic syntax.
Yes. You can you kinda just maybe walk
me through this for a second? And Sure.
What this is saying is that there is
a type option
which has
a generic parameter,
which means that that type can be
it it's a type option that you give
another type to to make the actual final
type.
So you can have an option of an
integer. You can have an option of a
string. You can have an option of a
vec. You can have an option of any
type in this case. And what we're doing
here is we have an option of an
integer, which in the standard library, the option
type is basically
either something or nothing,
which which basically is
either you it's it's kind of a nullable
type. It is
either you have an integer or you have
what's called none in Rust, or some languages
call it null. Rust calls it none.
Yeah.
Okay. Kinda reminds me of TypeScript.
I'm not sure if you're Yeah. Yeah. Right.
TypeScript also has I think it's called option
or maybe. I forgot. Yeah. It's it's it's
the it's the same option syntax. Well, very
similar at least. Yeah.
So the error then being is that when
we call this print number function is that
we're passing on just an explicit type. So
we need to wrap this somehow and Yeah.
Option.
That just
No. Some. So
have you done one of the enums
exercises yet?
I haven't done the enums exercises. No. Should
we go there? We could go there. We
could go through this first and, like, looking
at how options use will make you understand
enums better.
But I think it it I was I
was just wondering how how much I should
explain. But
yeah. So what option is is that
the the way it actually exist is
oops.
Like that.
And what it's what it is is that
it's either some and it contains
a thing
of the type that we passed in. So
in this case, because it's
it's u 16, what it actually is is
that this is a u 16,
something like that.
And and the none is
the null case.
So what we're doing is we're wrapping it
in sum to create an instance of option
of u 16 here.
Alright. Cool. And that's what the unwrap is
doing. We're just saying
either get me the none back or the
u 16
No. Unwrap is actually if it's none, I
I unwrap is I didn't don't expect it
to be none here. So if it was
none
and, like, basically,
in the program, it it caused a panic.
Alright. So I mean, I'm gonna do that
now.
Oops.
There we go. Like, if we did that,
it's going to panic.
Alright. Let's try that. So option one.
Oh, we've got another have to fix fix
other things first.
Okay. Yep. So we got oh, we expect
an option here for the number to add.
Oh, I guess we didn't fix all of
the cases.
Oh, yeah. Numbers as an array of option
type size five. Right? That's kinda a syntax
to send?
Yes.
Which means
this needs to be some number Yes. To
add.
Yep.
And
I haven't seen the syntax before.
So
Yeah. This is this is this is the
type, by the way. So if you say
let x so so the full, like, let
syntax is, like, let x
colon u 60 equals five.
And, of course, you can have a mut
here if you want.
And this is this is a type.
So using a colon, you can put a
type in.
And, also, you can do
you can do
well,
there's actually
if you compile, you'll see that there's a
compiler error here.
Okay. Let's do that.
And that's save.
Can can you go back? Actually, I didn't
see what the error was.
Oh, it it said that
I'm gonna run it again just in case
I hadn't saved. Yeah. I think it was
it. Okay. Yeah. And now we have possibly
uninitialized
numbers.
Yes.
Oh, yeah. That's the error you were gonna
say there. Right? So what we've done so
in Rust, you can, but you can do,
like, let x and not say what x
is and then, like, 10 lines later, say
x equal to 10.
But you have to do it in a
way that Rust knows that x is x
cannot be used in this part.
Wait. Oh, yeah. X cannot be used in
this part, and you have to do it
in a way that Rust knows that x
is fully initialized at the end. So here,
this array,
we start off with an uninitialized array, and
then we kind of just, like, fill it
with a for loop. And Rust cannot prove
that, like, you're actually creating the full array
here. So what you want to do
is
we can we can just do
like that.
Oops. That
and
it is this this part is actually unnecessary
now.
So this part is a type annotation, and
as you've seen in Rust, let statements usually
don't need type annotations.
In this case, we're adding one it it
was there to help us, I think, but
and what it's saying is that it's of
type option u 16.
Oh, it's a it's an array a fixed
size array of length five of type option
u 16,
but I think this will also work. And
this is a way of quickly initializing
an empty array
or
quickly initializing an array that has the same
same thing in its value. So you can
initialize
an array of integers like this.
You can initialize an array of strings like
this,
and they will all have the same value.
Okay.
So what's,
you know trying to think about, you know,
lessons that I take away from this is
idiomatic Rust. Do when you're doing a let
statement,
you rely on the syntax or, you know,
do you have a preference towards doing something?
When do you include them or not? You
include the type when Rust when Rust cannot
the idiomatic answer is you include the type
when Rust cannot compile without you doing it,
which typically occurs in more complicated cases.
So, like well, this is
but yeah. Yeah. Rust.
Yeah.
The
in this case, Rust knows that this is
a a a an a stir. So Rust
there's no point telling Rust it's a stir.
The only reason you do this if there's
some clarity that's lost for the reader,
and that can happen if you have some
really complicated type and you want the reader
of the code to know what the type
is.
But sometimes also you can have some complicated
type stuff going on, and you need to
tell Rust what the return type there is.
And Rust does have, like, some complicated things
that so for so I think a good
example of this is,
now this this this introduces a lot of
syntax at once, but I'm not gonna, like,
explain everything.
I'm just gonna say, like
so let's say we have, like, I don't
know.
That's an array.
So what I'm doing is, like, I'm creating
a I'm iterating over it,
and I'm adding one to each element.
And then what I'm doing is I'm saying,
give me a new vector made out of
this. And the thing is that this collect
function
can return a whole different set of types.
Like, you can get a vector out of
it. You can get a hash map out
of it. You can get a b tree
map out of it. You can get all
kinds of things. So here, I have to
say,
like
and doesn't matter really.
If to tell Rust that when you call
collect, I want the vector out of it.
And Rust will figure out what you're trying
to ask for. And there are some cases
so there are some cases where you're forced
to do this,
and you can also do
Okay. And I'm assuming that's just because those
types implement some sort of collect trait.
Is that what makes that work? It's called
from iterator. But yes. Exactly.
And the collect function is
generic over the from iterator type.
Gotcha. I mean, I understand a little bit
of that. So Yeah.
Okay. So the the automatic
you know, if I the more Rust I
write is, like, just don't bother with the
type annotations. Let the compiler do it. I
mean, the dev tools are pretty good too.
Right? If I hover over numbers here
Yeah.
Or no. It doesn't seem to know what
that is.
Maybe because the code doesn't compile yet.
I
I don't know if it does. It does.
Okay.
No idea why that doesn't work then.
Oh, it said Rust analyzer is currently indexing.
Okay.
That can happen.
So if if you run the code with
this, you'll see a panic, which is what
we're trying to do earlier.
Yeah. Right. Okay. So whenever we use the
unwrap function,
we we have to be very confident as
the developers that it's never Yes. Gonna have
a non value. Okay. Yes. And yeah.
Okay. Nice. Okay. Let's take a look at
options too.
Okay.
So expected one off. Okay. I've seen this
message before.
Don't remember what it meant, but I've seen
it before.
And then we expected
okay. So this looks like maybe it's a
syntax header.
It's mostly syntax, but there's more as far
as I can tell.
So let let's see which things you catch
first. Option two.
Yep.
There we go. I was closing those other
windows to see if Rust analyzer would
Oh, yeah.
Catch up with me again.
Don't wanna restart Versus Code because of our
session, so I'll just leave it. Okay.
Okay. So it's complaining here. Well, there's no
edge statement.
Well, yeah.
Is that it?
Kind of, but not really.
Alright. Let's see what new error message is
for You should look at the error and
see what it says.
It's
That's that's that's still another error. We can
fix that one later. We can fix this
one first. Or, I mean, depends on what
you want. Yeah. I can do that. I'll
I'll just text where I I mean, I'll
do my best. Well, no. I mean, I've
angered it.
Okay. So cannot find value and scope.
Yeah. We don't have a value.
Yeah. So make this an let statement whose
value is some type. Yes.
So
have you seen if let before?
Yeah. But I I found it a little
bit confusing. So, you know, let's just pretend
I haven't.
Yeah. So what's so what if let is
is that
so
see,
when when you say let x equal to,
like, five, what you're saying is that
so x is actually a pattern,
but
I I don't think it's a good point
to it's not a good idea to explain
patterns fully yet. But Well, that's the same
as Alexa. I think you said that as
of Alexa. They must do something similar there.
They say assignments aren't assignments. They're actually a
pattern match. I don't know if that's the
same here. So
this is syntactically
valid though, Rust.
So this is this is a range.
And you're saying that let the range from
five to six be five. This makes no
sense because if it this this doesn't this
doesn't make sense, but this is syntactically valid.
What goes in the let is a pattern
and what you're saying
and,
so you can do, like, let wild card
equal to five, and Rust will be like,
yes.
This this five is a wild card. Like,
good. And it will do nothing.
So and and and and in patterns, you
can put variable bindings, basically say that match
it to this and set set whatever match
to this variable. This is kind of like
regex capture groups,
but not really.
And so, normally, this this pattern needs to
be irrefutable. It needs to be such that
in a let statement, it needs to be
such that whatever
the input here needs to be able to
match to this. And that's that's fine for
x because
any input will match to x and set
to that value. That's fine for the wildcard
because anything matches to wildcard. That's not fine
for
let some phi
let some x equal to
because if if if this
oops. Alright. My keyboard shortcuts don't work, so
I'm gonna
if if if it were let sum x
equal to none, this would not match.
And then you've told you've told Rust to
say that this is the value of x,
but it can't execute this because it won't.
But this is where if let comes in
place,
where you can actually say
so if you say if let some value
equal to optional value, what you're saying is,
alright.
Try to match optional value against the pattern
sum of value.
If it succeeds,
this branch
will run,
and, also, this branch will have the value
from here.
And if not, the else branch.
So it's like
it's an if
with a little inbuilt match.
Okay.
That actually helps a lot. Okay.
It's like is that it fixed? I'm assuming
we probably want the same
Yes.
Here.
So if
optional value is a none, it's just gonna
run the second branch. Right? Yeah.
Yes. If it's none and it's not none,
but it will run the second second branch.
And you can try that out if you
want. But
It's not quite happy yet. Let's see.
Cannot find value lane 22.
Oh,
because I didn't type let. My bad.
Alright.
And it's saying option cannot be formatted on
lane 23.
So I wouldn't expect that to be an
option there.
K. So it's a vector of optional
Yes.
Eight bit integers.
So that's just the pop first. Right? And
then does the comparison against the sum values.
The same, it should be the the
It's the same thing. Yeah. So it's gonna
just yeah.
But the option type is still what's been
passed to print lane.
Wait. What?
That error
does not makes oh.
Oh, I see. So there's a fun fun
thing here, which is that pop itself returns
an option.
Because if the new vector's empty, what's it
gonna return? Nothing.
So it returns an option of the type.
So because we have a vector of options,
when pop returns an option of an option.
Does that make sense? Yeah. So we can
do that sum sum value.
Oh.
Did I not save it? Yeah. There we
go.
There.
Yeah.
And what it wants us to do here
is it wants us to
oh, and it it it it actually says
that vector dot pop adds another layer of
option t,
and you can just stack option t's. And
what it wants us to do is turn
it into a while let.
A while let is is like, so if
let is the sort of
pattern matchy version of if,
while let is kind of the pattern matchy
version of while,
which it does this
instead of saying if a condition do something,
it's as long as the condition is true,
do the thing. So it's a while loop,
but it's going to match on the
it's gonna match on the value and the
the results of this statement and give you
a value each time. So what this will
do is Oh, okay.
Whole thing and
return each value
until it stops
being
some some value.
Okay.
That makes sense. So it's just gonna keep
popping all those values off. Yep.
Is the
so is that something that does that mean
semantically, like, the actual con no. I don't
know if you'd say concrete one, but the
the pattern on the left and then the
concrete value on the right, is that always
the case? Can I swap those around? No.
You cannot. They're the patterns these are syntactically
two different
things. So, like, on the left, you have
a pattern.
Okay. So you you can also put something
like and and this will cause an infinite
loop, but you can put a wildcard pattern
there. But you can't put a wildcard pattern
on the other side.
Got it. Okay. Yeah.
Yeah. I think that's how Alexa works too,
but I can't really remember off the top
of my head. So
that passes. Now I'm just gonna break it
again
and do none.
And not break it, but that should print
the value doesn't contain anything. Right?
Yeah.
Oh, because
it doesn't know the type. And this is
where you use the syntax.
Well, it needs to be option of u
eight. This is not gonna compile either.
Yeah.
This is exactly where the syntax comes useful.
Not not that not that there's any point
to this kind of code really existing
because you're creating a value and then checking
what it is immediately.
So
but yeah.
It's gonna say it doesn't contain anything.
Yeah. I I guess the reason for typing
this kind of code is educational.
It's Exactly.
Me understand it.
Yeah. So in this case, Rust had no
idea what the type was.
Like, because it it you gave it none,
so it didn't know what was in the
option. It knew it was an option, but
it didn't know what went in it, so
it didn't have a complete type. And
it didn't need to because it would never
hit the branch that needed to, but it
it wants to know all the types completely.
So you have to tell it what the
type is.
Okay. One more thing before we move on
then.
Just because what you're talking about there is
the compiler trying to
infer the thing. Can I remove
the option here because it knows the x
isn't in?
Or because there's no none value. Right? So
so you can't remove it. You can replace
it with an a wildcard.
So types can have wildcards too. I suspect
this and, actually, in that case, because you
used VEC new here, so Rust already knows
that this is a VEC of something. It
doesn't know what that something is. I suspect
it won't compile. There's no reason why Rust
won't like, Rust could make this compile at
some point. My suspicion is that right now
this won't compile.
And
this is basically that. Or okay. It does.
So it's it's smart enough to be like,
it's a Vec, and it's it it's like,
I'll calm down. I won't I won't
I know you haven't told me what the
whole of Vec is, but I'll wait a
little bit and see if you can tell
me eventually. And so it's like, right now,
all I know is that it's a VEK
of something. And, oh, okay. You pushed something
to it. Now I know what it is.
But there there will be some cases that
are similar to this where it won't. So
yeah. What what I what I always do
is just, like,
write it without the types. And then if
it complains about types that I know what
they are, I just add them in.
Alright.
Clever compiler.
Okay. So that was options.
Let's you wanna jump over to enums then?
Sure. Yeah. Alright.
Let's run the test.
Enums
one.
Okay.
What have I got here? So no variant
or associated item named quit. Fan for enum
message lane 12.
There's a nice big fat to do saying,
well Yeah. So
that's just an empty enum. Right? It's it's
actually got no definitions types.
Okay.
I mean
Yeah.
We're assuming this is gonna work? That is
gonna work. Yeah.
Are the commas optional, mandatory?
Mandatory. Okay.
Yeah.
Commas are optional in a few cases, but
not for enums.
The last one is optional, but
yeah.
Yeah. I think if if they're mandatory anywhere,
I'll probably just put it on the last
one too.
Alright.
That works. So this syntax is
is that how we always let's see if
I can get auto complete. Yeah. Okay. That's
just how we reference members of a a
new node.
Yeah. Basically
so have you seen, like, pads and modules
yet? Like, have you seen the use statement?
Yes.
I have. So, like, this is this is
just a variant of that. And what's what's
going on here is that the enum message
kind of has children,
and they're
scoped under message.
So you can also do, like, use if
you did use message
quit, then you could just say quit.
You could just say quit. And that's what
happens with option, by the way. Because if
you notice, we didn't have to do option
some and option
none, and that's because by default, Rust directly
imports none and sum.
Alright.
Cool.
Yeah.
Can you know, I've used the syntax and
never really known what it does. Can you
maybe explain that to me too? Oh, sure.
So the print
this is the this is the print format
string the format string syntax in Rust is
pretty robust. And
oh, well, that didn't autocomplete.
So, like, when when you don't when you
use this, it means that this is
this parameter.
And you can also, like, number parameters.
You can even name them, like,
and you can say,
equal to five. You can do all kinds
of stuff here.
But when when you're just using braces with
no question mark, this means use what's called
the display implementation.
So there's a trait called display, and it's
it's
implemented for types
that have
that are intended to be displayed to the
to to the end user,
and the implementation tells you how you do
that display.
This thing means debug,
and what it means is that
this output might be ugly, and you probably
don't want to actually display it to the
user. In this case, actually, what the user
would see is just the words quit, echo,
move, or change color because so this this
custom this this derive is automatically deriving an
implementation.
But, for example, if you did
oh,
if you did derive on debug and then
destruct foo,
the the debug implementation would print some something
like
which you probably don't wanna show users.
Yeah.
So display is and, typically, display is something
that is written manually.
You will you will you will look at
your type, and you will decide how best
it is to how best to display it
to the user, and you'll write a manual
implementation, whereas debug is almost always custom derived
that way.
So
this is basically while debugging, if you use
the colon question marks and tags, you can
just
this is how you'll see your own types,
and it will show you basically everything that's
in them.
Okay. So I I just wanna confirm I
understood that correctly. If I had to move
that's arrived debug in this, will this fail
to compile? Nope. Yeah.
Cool. Yes. Alright. That makes a lot of
sense. You know, all you need is someone
just to explain it and, like, boom. Like,
cool. Alright.
So it's very it's very normal to just
slap derived debug on basically everything you write,
every structured enum in your program because at
some point or the other, you're gonna print
it out for debugging.
Cool. Good to know. Alright. Let's pop open
enums two.
Let's see. So we don't have any variants
for our message one, but I can see
here we do oh, these ones are getting
fancy.
Okay.
Oh, we got a plain move and a
plain quit.
We don't have a plain move, but we'll
get to that. Oh,
yeah. Let's do the other two because you've
seen the syntax there before.
Okay. So we got oh, well, let me
start from this. So we got change color.
Alright. So change color is a triple. Right?
So that means I did that. Yep. I
echo
triple of string.
Yep.
Yeah.
It's a stellar triple of this one, I
guess, so maybe I think it It's just
we just most enum variants look like this,
so we don't actually they're called technically called
tuple variants, but we just call them variants
or data full variants
because almost always, they look like this. Almost
always, they use the parentheses and not the
braces. The braces are actually pretty rare,
and you you use them when like, over
here, it's pretty obvious that this is red,
green, and blue. But if you had, like,
a bunch of u 30 twos and they
all were different things that, like, were different
concepts,
it is often better to just name them.
And that's where the thing used for move
comes in, where you actually have to give
them a name.
And that that you just do, but, like,
it it uses the struct syntax
like that.
Nice. So enums
can really be a pretty flexible component then.
Yes. And I can I mean, one of
the things I'm thinking of in my head
as soon as I've seen this is, like,
you know,
if I wanna write endpoints that take gRPC
messages, like, that could just be an email
of all the different messages I can receive
on an endpoint, and I could match
and work on that or something? Exactly. Yes.
And match is how you usually deal with
enums.
Like, I mean, I I showed the match
with just values earlier, and I'm sure that
probably the next exercise will have this. But
I showed the match with values earlier, but
the match statement takes patterns. So you can
do things like match
match message and say,
move x y
something, quit something, echo something.
Ah, cool. I like it. Alright. Let's see
if we fixed this then.
Items too. We did. Okay.
What's this call function?
Oh, no. It's just the ah, okay.
And all it does is it uses the
debug implementation.
And I guess if you run it, you'll
realize that the debug implementation of this enum
is not very pretty.
It's not something you'll wanna show to the
user.
This one? Yeah. This is this
like, this is not something
like, if if if you had a user,
end user, not a programmer using your application,
you probably wouldn't wanna show them change color
200, two 50 five, two 50 five. You'd
wanna show them, like,
change the color to
this color or something. So Yeah. Okay. Also,
this is the this is probably an internal
message, so you'd never show it to the
user in the first place. But yeah.
Oh, you'd hope so. But, you know, I'm
a bit of a caretaker all of this
stuff. So
I'm just gonna make them smaller and make
this bigger. Is that gonna
does the compiler know? The compiler does know.
I'm your compiler.
Cool.
And is there I mean,
U S R A 2 is not exactly
massive. Right? I mean, is there only special
circumstances you would choose anything smaller? Like, is
there any rules around that? There's nothing smaller
than u eight. I mean, in this case,
if you're talking about two fifty six bit
color,
you probably wanna use a u eight so
people don't give you a number that's too
big.
Yeah. Like, that that's basically when you start
using u eights. And often,
you actually want to size optimize. Often, like
I mean, I've worked on browsers and stuff,
and in browsers, you often have these trucks
that are just everywhere.
Like, for example, the node type in JavaScript,
like, doc for elements,
everything is a node, you need to allocate
that again and again. So if you if
you can just shave off, like
if you can pack a bunch of things
that don't need to be 32 bit integers
into eight bit integers, then you can just
have more of them, and you don't end
up allocating so much because you're allocating them
thousands and thousands of times.
Cool. That's good to know.
Alright. Let's see what this last one is,
and then we'll decide what we wanna finish
on. So
in a message, a struck point
oh, yeah. I'm gonna need a another message
here.
So let's see.
Oh, I see.
So variant or associated item change color is
not found here, and this is on
Lane 54.
Yeah.
So this is the state
process.
Oh, so I'm assuming this process maybe doesn't
match?
Yes. Except we have to write it. Ah,
there we go.
This will create a match expression to process
the different message variants.
Sorry.
The
message.
What does it pass in? Just a straight
up type. So that's just gonna be, like,
this. Right?
Yeah.
Well,
not quite. But we should first define the
enum
because that's also not done.
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright. What do we got then? Let's just
copy these.
You also won't want the message colon colon.
Yeah.
So we got our quick message. We've got
our change color,
which actually needs to be
So there's a subtle difference between this one
and the last one. And if you compile
it, you might notice.
What was that? Just double brackets. So it's
actually expecting a triple of
Yeah. It's what it's decided what they've decided
is that the color type that they're using
is a triple itself. Yeah. Okay.
This one just has to be string and
this one just needs to know.
Oh,
well, this is a type. Right? So can
I just do This
is just like the string one? So now
this is they've made it a little bit
clearer,
cleaner,
and so now there's just a point type.
So the Rust compiler doesn't care. The structure
is defined after the enum, none of the
ordering matters. Okay. Cool. Within the same crate,
everything can find everything. I mean, if if
you create something recursive that it doesn't like,
it might cause a problem. But you you
can you can have you can have self
referential stuff as well.
Okay.
State looks fine. So now we're back to
this match statement then. Yeah.
So we're matching on message, and we wanna
alright. What was this? Quiet was just empty,
wasn't it? Yep.
So well, we want okay. We can just
do an empty for now. Yeah. I thought
maybe if I could just get it to
compile.
Yeah. That's a good point.
The test failed, so it compiled.
That's good.
Yeah.
So what's it actually expecting? It wants me
to
set the properties on the state to be
the values. Right? Yeah. But the but the
state function already has methods that do this.
So I think we just need to call
them.
Ah, okay. So for quit, we're just calling
quit?
Self dot quit. But yeah.
And then we wanna handle message,
change color,
message.
Right?
Nope.
Remember what we did in the if let
to get access to the thing inside the
enum?
Oh, yeah. So
we need to do
that?
Yep. K.
Yeah.
Also,
just
to note because so remember when we when
the color was not a tuple?
If if it was like this, you'd do
something like this,
if that makes sense.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Because this tuple
is encapsulated. Just a single this is just
a single thing. Yep. Okay.
And we've got one more, don't we? So
Echo. Echo.
It also takes a param. So
See.
Neat.
Cool. And I'm assuming removing this, the compiler
is gonna complain that we don't handle all
the cases. Exactly.
Yep.
We we could just do that, but then
the
test will fail. So No. The test will
actually pass
because the echo thing doesn't do anything that
can be tested.
Alright. We'll leave it like that.
Alright. Let's pick one
more.
Yeah.
Anything you think would be fun to do?
I mean
I I mean, what what do you what
would you like to do?
Okay. So there's a couple of things. I
think let's pick the one that you're most
interested in. Now I think maybe doing something
around testing would be cool. Clippy's jumping out
at me because I don't know what Clippy
is.
Yeah. Maybe one of those two.
So Clippy is
Clippy is Rust's linting tool,
and the Rust compiler tells you when your
code's wrong. Clippy tells you when your code's
bad
or not
perfect.
Okay.
Yeah.
Alright. Yeah.
Well, I guess we could take a really
quick look at Clippy, and then maybe we'll
take a quick look at tests, we'll that
should take us up to our time. So
Yeah.
So Clippy is a tool
is a collection of lens to analyze your
code.
Okay. Let's run Clippy one and see. Is
it I saw it just run Rustling Stone.
I'm not actually sure how they do the
thing.
But
ah, okay. Yeah. They've they've set it up
so that it fails to compile when Clippy
has an issue. So the Clippy Clippy warnings
show up as Rust warnings when you use
Clippy.
So they look the same.
Okay. And we've got a whole bunch okay.
So this is, like, one of these Lent
rules is on by default, which means that
it's telling us our code could be better.
Yeah. And this is telling us that we're
comparing a 32 bit float with a 64
bit float, which is maybe bad. Oh, no.
We're just comparing floats.
It like, we're comparing floats for equality.
And the problem with comparing floats for equality
is, for example,
things like
one
three
divided by two point is not actually 1.5
because floats are weird.
Yeah. This is the weird precision thing. I
think every language has that. Right? Everything. Yeah.
Everything with I I three floats has has
that. So so the
the idiomatic way of doing float comparison where
you're comparing for equality, like, x greater than
y is fine, but x equal to y
or not equal to y is
you
you what you do is you compare them
up to, like, a small delta,
like, a small error value.
And what people often do is so if
you look at the error message, it actually
tells you what to do.
Use absolute
I'll just copy this.
So
if
and we need to pick pick an error
value.
So you could just put point zero zero
one there.
It's a pretty big number, but you like,
yep.
What did you tell me to put that?
Point zero Some some small number. Probably smaller
than that, actually. Like, just a bunch of
zeros.
The the clip, yeah, actually goes on something
else. Yeah. You're you're using, like, a very
small error value. You're saying that I'm
I I consider these to be equal if
they're close if they're closer than that number.
Yeah. I understand that. Yes. So we're doing
y minus x. Absolute. And then checking to
see if the differential is bigger than the
small number that we're willing to accept as
an error margin. Okay. Yeah.
Cool. And the message probably would have told
me that. I'm not sure. Said there's an
f 32 epsilon. So the Rust standard library
you has
like, you can also what you can put
here, and I think you might have to
import it. But
if you do this
or f 64
because we're using f 60 fours. If you
do this,
it will that is the value the Rust
standard library recommends.
Yeah. That worked. Compiled and
And the Epsilon is just
Rust standard library accepted marginal value, I guess.
Yeah. Actually
Does it define it if I hover? Or
not because my analyzers are not okay.
This is this
is the difference between one and the next
largest representable number.
So
this is actually kind of, like, the smallest
difference. Often, you will want something, like, bigger.
It like, epsilon's very small. So it depends
on what you want. Like, if it's if,
like, if you really care about that much
precision and your numbers are that precise, you
would use Epsilon. But in this case, maybe
not. Like,
in this case, you just figure out where
you want things to be the same.
Alright. Sweet.
Alright.
What does Clippy two tell me then? Let's
just run it.
Also, if you're, like, on your own projects
to run Clippy, you just run cargo Clippy.
Oh, yeah. I I don't know how this
project is set up, I don't wanna run
that against everything here. But This is this
project is set up differently.
So this is complaining because
it says
for loop over an option, which is an
option.
This is more readable.
Okay. So this is telling me that my
code is just more readable if I change
it to an outlet.
Yeah. Like like I said, it doesn't tell
you your code is wrong. It tells you
your code is bad.
Alright. Okay. Used to its warnings then, I
guess. Yeah.
And you can also not it's not that
big a deal to not use Clippy. Some
people it it often teaches you things, so
people like to use it as a learning
tool.
But
so what it's saying here is that
so you know how you can do, like,
four x in vector?
So vector is an iterable, which means you
can give it to a for loop or
iterator functions.
So it turns out option is also an
iterable, and it it's an iterable that either
if it's some, it gives you that one
value. If it's none, it gives you nothing.
Just like a vector is an iterable that
gives you all the values it has.
So sometimes
this sometimes causes confusion.
You you rarely want to say iterate over
everything in this option because that's just an
if let.
So what Clippy is telling you to do
is just use an if let here
because this is confusing because people don't usually
remember that an option isn't iterable.
It's like, there there are good reasons for
option to be an iterable, but it also
leads to sharp edges like this where you
have a four loop and you're like, oh,
this is looping over many objects. And it
turns out it's only looping over the option,
so it's only looping over one.
Yeah. That makes sense.
Okay.
And if yeah. Okay. That makes sense.
Let's
yeah. We don't need to save that one.
Let's go for
let's trace tests.
So, I mean, we've already kinda seen this
syntax a few times now because some of
the rustling exercises actually ship with a test.
So
are assertions always macros?
Yeah.
Assertions are macros because
they're macros because they actually kind of
they
the like, if you if you say assert,
like, one equal to two,
it will actually print this part out along
with the assertion. And I think you can
use you can even use format string syntax
if it fails. Like
actually, I'm not sure. I don't think I
don't think you can, but
it it will actually print this out. So
they're they're macros so that that can look
good.
Okay.
Otherwise, you'll just get assertion failed and then,
like, a string if you added one. But
if you yeah.
Over here I'm just asserting that the statement
evaluates to true instead of brackets. That's Yeah.
That's it. Okay.
Run
test
one.
Yep.
And if if if it were if it
one one equal equal to two,
you'll see that it'll say assertion failed
one equal equal to two. So it needs
to be a macro so it can actually
say that one equal equal to two because
if it was just a function, the function
has no idea
what expression you put in its parameters. It
only knows the value of that expression.
So that that's that's why it's a macro.
Alright. Cool.
And
what is this CFG test?
So
so in in in Rust, basically, this is
this is saying only do this in test
mode. Only compile this module in test mode.
So right now, it doesn't really matter. If
you just did
if you just took this function and put
it outside, it wouldn't matter. But often, sometimes
you'll have, like, imports and stuff
that you're using in your tests.
It is standard practice to put all of
your unit tests in, like, modules that are
called test or tests, and you put a
CFG test on it. So the normal normal
compilers don't even see that code.
And,
when it's in test mode to see if,
their compilers invoked with CFG test on,
And now then suddenly this module is enabled,
and then it finds the test. It's it
it prevents it prevents like, if you're writing
a library because, again, like, these are you
use
this is this is how you'd write a
unit test, typically.
And if your library has lots of unit
tests, you don't want downstream crates to care
about them, and you don't you don't want,
like, your imports to be mixed in with
the other imports. For example, in your test,
you might be importing some test dependencies,
and you want to be able to import
them without the rest of the code having
to also import it. So you use CFG
and you do some cargo feature stuff and
a bunch you use a bunch of things.
But yeah.
Okay.
And that just tells that that that's a
test that should be run to evaluate the
a a service or not? Does that mean
I can have functions inside of this module
block that don't get run as tests? Yep.
Only things that are pound test are evaluated
as tests.
Okay. And you said that unit tests should
be in this format. So, like, integration,
acceptance test, they all live in a test
folder then, I guess. Yes. There's a test
folder, and you still write tests with pound
test, but you won't use CFG test because
that folder will always be invoked with CFG
test.
Okay. Gotcha. Cool.
Alright. Let's pop
over one more. So
are these just introducing new macros?
Okay. That was a bit different. Okay.
So this isn't a set equals?
I mean, I feel like we just didn't
necessarily calls. Right?
Oh, is that because alright. Okay. That's gonna
accept this syntax. Right?
Yep.
And and we we actually want to fix
this so that assert can just do this.
But what the reason it's a separate macro
is so that if it's not equal, it
can actually just tell you these are the
two values.
Instead of just saying assertion failed, it'll say
assertion failed because one is not equal to
two.
Okay. I guess that's not really a problem
for simple cases where it's just two numbers.
But for maybe you're comparing
two objects to structs, something like that, it
may be more important for those Yes. For
two numbers. Separately. It often it actually often
matters for numbers. Like, you might do assert
equal
vec dot len
and zero
to make sure that it's zero. There's you
can also assert that it's empty. But if
it's not zero, you might wanna know, like,
does it have one thing? Does it have
500?
So, like, you often do it that. Even
like, I've I've used this for integers.
Okay.
I'm assuming there's other. Yeah. There we go.
Those are not equals. So Yep.
Also, there's, like, I think, a proxy. There's
there's a bunch.
I lost the message just now, so I'll
stick with that.
That's on test two. It's happy.
Just
find out.
Yeah.
Yeah. Because because they're two different parameters, it
can actually separate them on this view. Yes.
Okay.
Alright. Let's see what this last one is,
and then we can finish up there. So
we have a function doing modules even,
returns a bill,
and we have to just write the test
to make sure the function works.
K.
So if I call as even
before,
we would expect that to be true.
Yep.
You
don't actually have to have the equal equal
to true.
Alright. Okay. Yeah. Of course. Yeah. Because the
the statement within the macro has to evaluate.
Okay.
Well, you'd have to And this one does.
Right? Or You can just put a not
there. Some people actually do prefer the equal
equal to false over the not just because
you it's easy to forget the not. It's
easy to miss it while reading. But yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. I've always been taught to try
and, like, I had this drummed into me
from
very early days. They always put the static
value on the left so it's easier to
read. I don't know if that's true, but
Yeah. That's true.
Those are called Yoda conditions. Yoda conditions. Yeah.
Yeah.
I just always had that in green with
me and this kind of stuck. So I'll
just I'll just copy that too. Alright. I've
got one more test to do. So alright.
I already did that.
Oh.
Well
no. Wait.
Is false then odd?
Left is one. Right is two.
Oh, it's it's failing on test two. It's
failing on the other test.
You're running the wrong test.
Oh.
Sorry. Oh, you're running the wrong file. Yeah.
Yeah. Each file has multiple tests.
That was confusing.
But I don't I don't like when I
look at trivial code and I can't work
at what's going on. So that's good.
Alright. Awesome. Thank you for that. That was
really good fun.
Yeah.
So that was we got through quite a
lot there. I think that was a really
good exploration of pretty much everything that was
left in these exercises. There's only a few
things
there.
So
I just wanna say thank you for, you
know, taking the time out of your day.
I know you must have a lot on
your plate. You're starting a new role next
week. So, you know, thank you for making
the time here and and kinda guiding me
through this and sharing your knowledge. It was
it was really really really good. I enjoyed
it. Yeah. You're welcome. This is really fun.
Thank you. Well, you have a great rest
of your day. Enjoy your weekend. Good luck
with your new job at Google next week
and thank you again. Yeah.
Cheers. Thank you for having me. It was
great.
Cheers.